all right folks pack it in they might
really be killing OverWatch this time
after years of poor balancing decisions
and a few months of messed up metas in
OverWatch 2 blizzard has made a decision
that has gone just too far starting soon
each and every hero is going to be able
to passively heal themselves let's talk
about
it all right before we get into the rest
of this video I've got some exciting
news for you yes people we've brought
back over explained for the noobs who
missed it back in 2017 we launched a
show where Josh taught normies the
history of Gaming's biggest memes and
emotes and 40 years two kids and one dab
rig later he's back to do it again
across eight new episodes Josh and the
Gang will guide you through the rich
history of copy pastas try to explain
why Bots are taking over your favorite
games and take a look at why forsen's
Community is so obsessed with spread
setting his face across the internet new
episodes are going live Sundays at 300
p.m. so make sure you're subscribed
you've got notifications on so you don't
ever miss an episode okay now let's get
back to OverWatch okay so in a blog post
published on Friday OverWatch 2's
director Aaron Keller shared some news
about the development team's plan for
2024 and in that post he made a huge
announcement soon all tanks and damage
Heroes will be able to passively
self-heal much like supports already can
in OverWatch 2 every role has a passive
tanks are harder to knock back but
charge ultimate slower damage Heroes
Have bonus reload speed after a kill and
healers heal a little bit whenever
they're not in combat the idea when they
came up with these specific rooll
passives back in 2021 when they were
working on OverWatch 2 was to refine
what each of these roles purposes in a
match was we want to try to make them
more toe-to-toe Brawlers and less
characters that just stand back and
protect other people in practice this
actually has led to more focused play
within a given role but OverWatch 2 has
had other problems from the war over 5v5
versus 6v6 to the constant parade of
broken new Heroes to the busted ass rank
system to supports being overpowered to
damage spikiness basically every aspect
of the game has been a mess but the
recent balance changes have been
horrendous like genuinely what we need
is a global damage and healing Nerf so
blizzard has a lot of work to do going
into season 9 and for now they're
choosing to focus on two things
encouraging team play and reducing
damage spikes unfortunately the
community seems to largely agree that
the change they've proposed to make is
only going to make things worse my first
reaction to this is this doesn't surely
this just makes some Heroes completely
redonkulous like a sojan we were just
talking about if she's just got a heal
when she's not in combat there's even
less reason to play
Soldier what that's got to be really
toned down that's actually mental there
are two major takeaways here one
blizzard wants to relieve the
frustration that you feel when your
supports just aren't carrying their
weight or when they're off killing
people instead of healing you and two
blizzard wants to create a game where
generally speaking damage matters less
because everyone will just be healing
that damage away now while blizzard says
they're interested in increasing team
play in general they're pretty quick to
note that sometimes they want to pull
back into the hands of the individual
players but some people have noted that
this particular change might make team
play entirely irrelevant which one is it
do you want the game to be more based on
teamwork and mechanics or do you not
because you say here that you do would
you not agree that letting players all
passively heal as a collective takes
away from Teamwork because players no
longer have to work together to get
things which in which actually does the
opposite of incentivizing them to work
together it makes them want to play more
individually because they they can heal
on their own they don't have to work
with their team as much right think of
it this way if you're playing DPS and
you can passively heal outside of combat
you're not at all incentivized to group
up with your team and fight together
you're incentivized to jump in take a
fight and then leave playing completely
for yourself in fact in theory flanking
Heroes like Tracer and Sombra could
become extremely powerful with the
ability to self-heal but maybe a little
bit more flashy Tracer game play
wouldn't really be the worst thing I
don't know it's probably going to
facilitate more flank style gameplay you
can play on your own um it's going to
probably Giga buff Tracer um sojan would
be buffed from it or anyone who wants to
operate on the flank the Sombra Giga
buff anyone who really shouldn't have
their own heal if they've got a heal
that's probably going to make them
really really strong for tanks I'm not
really too bothered cuz the Tank's not
going to be off running around the map
they might be and if they are you're
probably going to lose the game unless
it's Road Hog he's still probably going
to lose the
game or maybe not I don't know but weird
that is weird on on tanks maybe they
could have come up with something a bit
different for tanks but I'm really
worried about that being stupidly crazy
on on DPS and we know the way blizzard
tend to operate is um it'll probably be
way too good to begin with and then
it'll get toned down but what is also
interesting here is you might be going
into this world where healing in
OverWatch is no longer you know the job
of the support it's it's your job you
know you got to keep yourself alive then
if you're playing support you know your
teammates can heal themselves so you
just go off and do your own thing alone
then if you're a tank you're kind of
just screwed the role was already
relatively unimpactful in the current
state of OverWatch 2 and now the rest of
your team is going to have less
incentive to group up and play with you
your healers aren't healing you your DPS
isn't defending you they're off trying
to get kills on their own the fear is
that every hero is going to feel like it
has to be this damage dealing jack of
all trades or it's just not worth
playing I don't think they understand
their game and this kind of this kind of
reaffirms my belief that they they don't
understand how implementing these things
are going to affect the game before they
do it or even when they do it to be fair
to Blizzard Aaron Keller took to Twitter
on Sunday to clarify that it was
probably a mistake to reveal the healing
passive change without the context of
all the other changes coming with it as
I keep alluding to OverWatch players
pretty unanimously agree that something
needs to change and this is for sure a
massive change the problem is that
players and Pros alike are pretty
dubious that this change isn't exactly
faithful to the game they fell in love
with but I do want to make it clear that
it is still possible that this all works
out in the long run low key I'm kind of
I'm actually kind of down with it I'm
down to see what happens in Theory
giving every character healing could
make the game a lot less frustrating
when you're queuing up with randoms and
it could make it even more interesting
at a high level of play but it's still
hard to see it's solving the major
issues that people have with the game
OverWatch clearly needs a massive
shakeup and to their credit blizzard
does seem to know what the problems are
this is just their first step in trying
to fix it it's hard to say if this
change is going to save a struggling
game or just drive it deeper in into the
dirt what do you think can they save
OverWatch 2 or is this one change that
has just gone too far let me
know I think it's definitely a game that
needs drastic change and this sounds
like an extremely drastic move so
hopefully this in combination with some
of the other stuff they alluded to in
season 9 and some balance changes that
help make the change not too overpowered
is the the shake up the game needs